stavo uccidendo
ciao a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fatti gente non ci
siamo il nuovo episodio di the forest
se n'è accorto ragazzi porca [ __ ]
ascolta ascolta stai calmo stoffa vj
www.uai.it grade vuoi fumare e ciò ad
accendere tranquillo guarda quel
coniglio che lo regalo e tua basta che
non dici a nessuno io e tu non hai visto
niente qui si sentì e majin bu ti muovi
off se vuoi guarda ciò del fuoco
mangiamo vorrei che a sei fatta arrivare
qui recatevi ammazzarlo per forza perché
se non dice dove sono ma [ __ ]
brutto stronzo
mica che porta vai vai vai veloce
bastardo si è morto di crepare la vita
proprio [ __ ] trovato regala così
impari brutto stronzo bene poi ascolta
siccome sa stanotte sono solo e ho
bisogno di compagnia d'ora mi come vieni
guarda dormiamo insieme vieni qua ecco
così almeno ciò la compagnia non era un
bel rifugio
lo so che facevo un po schifo e lo
dicevo anche io vado al fuoco è rimasta
c'è tutta la notte non si sa come va va
ragazzi cuciniamo un po di di coniglio
per colazione vuoi favorire zio che mi
sto affezionando a quest'uomo ragazzi
credo che lo chiamerò josh ascolta josh
io la mattina non maggio coniglio di
solito mangio tipo non so cro san
brioche cappuccini se hai voglia allora
io ti metto qui che prende il sole
ecco dove doveva definito josue josua
ragazzi ho perso il mio amico nelle
rocce cioè non solo vediamolo sia finito
però vabbè dai pazienza almeno mi sono
sbarazzato del cadavere bene ragazzuoli
sono a posto devo trovare
dei tronchi per fare l'altra bella tra
campamento ce la posso fare ragazzi
tranquilli è l'unica roba che devo fare
è cercare di non incappare negli stronzi
di prima che mi hanno veramente
impossibile che si che siano ovunque ma
si può
ok rega ci siamo via giù il primo tronco
mai così dai tagliando la legna con
questa ciaia yahoo che se arriva un
altro ma gas in testa gliela do che
stoppa o e tagliato la madonna
fantastico non la vuoi amore che ruotano
già giu
c'è perfetto ma basta che non vanno a
finire in mare tanto ragazzi con l'aereo
lì vicino al sicuro non mi sento tanto è
un accampamento magari poi più avanti i
secoli lo cambierò se vendono casa
hollywood mi prendo quella se casca in
testa a qualcuno potrei morire dal
ridere ve lo dico c'è l'intervallo tipo
a scuola ragazzi mi sono attualmente le
palle di tagliare alberi potevo fare
boscaiolo non so perché ho scelto la
strada know you tube cielo fatto ragazzi
dopo un anno e mezzo sono riuscito a
trovare tutti quanti i tronchi ma posso
costruire l'arca di noè posso fare mio
dio posso costruire la zattera per
scappare questa cosa prima dottor
aretini giusto senza temi non me ne vado
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye carico
carico 8 9 10 11 a preciso incredibile
ce famo non uno di più non uno di meno
fantastico ci ha messo un anno per
raccogliere libro ce l'ho fatta grazie a
dio
che bello posso salvare qua dentro o lei
siamo al secondo salvataggio ragazzi la
prima volta nella storia di the forest
che riesco a fare una roba così c'è va
beh posso usarlo anche per andare su non
a parole mi fanno un imboscata in 26
posso scappare anche di quattro ragazzi
sono salito di nuovo perché tanta
ragazzi siccome mattino presto direi che
posso andare a farmi un paio di giri di
ricognizione ha previsto accennino è
sempre acceso ma non si scarica tipo
acceso dall'altro ieri va bè ragazzi a
parte tutto suscita a farmi
l'accampamento quindi se crepe o dovrei
di partire di liriche non è male visto
che ogni volta che crea questo gioco
riparto da zero
la barca devo ispezionarla subitissimo
perché devo vedere se riesco a trovare
rode buone alle tartarughe e vero che ci
sono gli squali anche da stare
attentissimo ok perfetto c'è il timone
questo boccio sarra st barca per andar
via non sa cos'è il summer edition yacht
addirittura c'è il magazine fantastico
no che figo hanno aggiunto sottocoperta
fantastico si sta da dio ma perché ti
dovresti mangiare un teschio bongiorno
ma lei è per caso la moglie del tizio
che ucciso prima nel nome di jesus io ti
dico di farti un bagno ha coperto la
prendo io grazie i teli li prendo io
grazie mille sexy cos'è la nuova
copertina di vanity fair che è rihanna
non voglio saperlo zio meglio non fare
domande a volte c'è del latte veramente
missing zaccari non guarda non voglio
sapere che fine ha fatto zakelj spero si
stia divertendo più di me se sta roba
una cassetta posso salvare anche qui
quindi ragazzi o due case in poche
parole se a questa qui che casa mia che
laggiù fantastico ragazzi ci siamo dopo
uscì posso uscire di qua tanto visto già
tutto ai vai buttato buttarlo giù buttar
giù che cazzo di salvagente ma è finto
ragazzi sulla spiaggia c'è uno squalo
c'è uno squalo morto prendiamo un paio
di provviste e poi direi di salvare la
partita che prova ad andare nelle
catacombe che ho visto prima su chiamai
volare vicino a fa vj quando incalzato
zio
ricordatelo inutile che fai con la
faccia mac è la madonna mica se solo ci
fosse la connessione internet dai zio
almeno controlla facebook ma [ __ ]
almeno c'è minecraft installato che
almeno faccio qualche partita ecco se
c'era minecraft non c'è più credo è c'è
una top una tomba chi è richiesta tomba
e la tomba dello yacht ma lo yacht sta
li trovate un'altra cassetta ragazzi
vediamo che sia la cassetta di renato
zero che ci voglia di ascoltarlo adesso
[Musica]
ma cos'è dai la musica ma non è così non
è vero ragazzi ma come cazzo fai almeno
grazia di dio almeno sono suonare su
un'isola con la musica ami recupera
l'energia la musica fantastico non
sapevo cristo spendi spendi spendi
spendi spendi spegne spegne buttala via
avuta come cazzo si spegne aiuto spegni
ti stronzo di merda o grassi mi chiamano
male che c'e l'accendino che mi salva il
culo passata della gente bruttissima via
via che era gazzoli siamo tornati
all'accampamento devo vedere un paio di
robe prima di partire in nelle catacombe
a far crescere il cibo veramente no
vabbè che ti cassa cosa per preservare
la carne ci vuole il tavolino la madonna
che figo la carne la metto tipo qui
prese appena esco ciò proprio la carne
in faccia fantastica
le fiji servono per mandare via a quegli
stronzi lì il problema è che mi fa
schifo
cioè veramente brutta vabbè io la metto
qua ok se non avessi verso il mio amico
nelle rocce a quest'ora avrei già dei
pezzi di corpo io riesco a fare sta roba
qua alla fine non mi troveranno mai
perché hanno paura l'istitut e non so
come mai ok ragazzi ho trovato i due
tronchi che mi servivano per sta roba
qui adesso mi serve so ho piantato anche
i semi quindi mi cresce il cibo c'è
ragazzi mai fatta una roba così da
proinso gioco fai un fuoco andiamo ad
mangiavano andiamo a dormire che domani
vado nelle catacombe voglio vedere che
succede che se magna oggi una roba nuova
dai facciamo
facciamo un po di di questo che ancora
non ho mangiato che bello che ci siamo
perfetto zio comprime che è successo a
mia mi sono scontrato col fuoco che
genio o su entra grazie e mi servirà non
posso dormire si deve scaricare il costo
per dormire non sapevo vabbè allora
niente aspettiamo che che si ricarichi
non so come mai non posso dormire quando
voglio allora dài non importa nel
frattempo vedo che cosa posso costruire
con quel legno liga stonewall su questo
devo fare sono praticamente dei muri che
non ti permettono di di venire qua
quindi io faccio così
ok e se faccio così quei deficienti non
dovrebbero essere in grado di di venirmi
a prendere quanti tronchi mi servono per
fa sta roba
un botto mi servono almeno una decina di
tronchi forse anche di più direi che ci
siamo meritati una bella notte di sonno
perfetto rai che solo i miei e mattina
direi che possiamo andare in
esplorazione prima di partire vi accenno
ragazzi che pericolosissimo quello che
sto facendo perché potrei morire di
brutto proprio perché le catacombe sono
piene di oggetti utili quindi mi
serviranno e soprattutto magari riesco a
trovare timi però allo stesso tempo sono
pericolosissime ma veramente pericolose
non mi ricordo assolutamente dove
diavolo era quella roba lì però vabbè
cerchiamo la fame giaccio fame ma come
cazzo è vero c'è mattina devo fare
colazione allora facciamo così prima
troviamo la caverna e poi mi fermo un
attimino mangiare ok è una caverna
questa o si che una caverna
bene allora non ho trovato il coso per
calarmi giù che prima c'era un corso per
calarsi ecco adesso non lo più trovato
ma in compenso ho trovato proprio
l'entrata va bene allora facciamo un
bass camp veloce palle che devo trovarmi
le foglie ogni volta c'è una roba invece
basche 2 maroni seri proprio ok famose
st colazione che non ne possono più non
sentite odore di coniglio voi e che so
già che ne approfittate stronzi funghi
si mangiano i funghi
la paura non c'è paura magari crepo di
avvelenamento non è neanche troppo
lontano da casa mia quindi ce la posso
fare arrivare qua baby china soda
fantastico 06 appostissimo allora
ragazzi ci siamo io direi che possiamo
entrare o la va o crepe via d'accordo
ragazzi conclude episodio e anche questa
volta mi vorreste uccidere perché lo
concluso nel punto sbagliato
questo vuol dire che foto e sega
consenso che è piaciuto l'argomento è un
mi piace ai capace di facebook coniglio
trovate in descriptions scusate se non
se lo che si rispetti non ci vediamo la
prossima vita della ragazza